SARASOTA COUNTY.
SEAN?
>> Sean: ALL RIGHT, THANKS FOR
THAT CHARLES, WE APPRECIATE IT.
>>> TONIGHT ALSO AT THIS HOUR AS
MILLIONS FROM FLORIDA ARE
SUFFERING FROM THE DEVASTATING
IMPACT OF HURRICANE IAN, THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES,
WELL, HE'S ENJOYING A LAVISH
DEMOCRATIC FUNDRAISER.
HE PRETTY MUCH IGNORED THE
HURRICANE ALL DAY AND INSTEAD
EARLIER HE SPOKE AT A PRE
SCHEDULED WHITE HOUSE CONFERENCE
ON HUNGER AND NUTRITION.
NOW THE CONFERENCE HONORED THE
LATE CONGRESSWOMAN, JACKIE
WALARSKI WHO HELPED ORGANIZE THE
EVENT.
SHE DIED IN A TRAGIC CAR CRASH
IN AUGUST.
AT THE TIME OF HER DEATH BIDEN
ORDERED FLAGS TO BE LOWERED AT
HALF MAST, RELEASED A HEART FELT
TRIBUTE TO THE LONG SERVING
LAWMAKER AND IS EVEN MEETING
WITH HER FAMILY TOMORROW.
BUT TODAY APPARENTLY BIDEN
THOUGHT SHE WAS STILL ALIVE.
YOU CAN'T MAKE IT UP.
>> I WANT TO THANK ALL OF YOU
HERE FOR -- CLUB BIPARTISAN
ELECTED OFFICIALS LIKE
REPRESENTATIVE GOVERNOR BRAWN,
SENATOR BOOKER, REPRESENTATIVE
JACKIE -- JACKIE YOU HERE?
WHERE'S JACKIE.
I DON'T THINK SHE WAS GOING TO
BE HERE.
TO HELP MAKE THIS A REALITY.
.
>> Sean: I DON'T HAVE WORDS FOR
THIS.
USUALLY THESE OBVIOUS EXAMPLES
OF BIDEN'S CON NAHTIVE DECLINE
ARE TOTALLY IGNORED BY MOST IN
THE MEDIA MOB BUT TODAY MULTIPLE
REPORTERS DEMANDED ANSWERS
RIGHTLY SO FROM THE WHITE HOUSE
PRESS SECRETARY.
HOW DID THAT HAPPEN?
WHAT IS GOING ON?
WHAT IS WRONG HERE?
NEEDLESS TO SAY, THE WHITE HOUSE
PRESS SECRETARY DIDN'T HAVE VERY
GOOD ANSWERS.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WHAT HAPPENED IN THE HUNGER
EVENT TODAY?
THE PRESIDENT APPEARED TO LOOK
AROUND THE ROOM FOR AN AUDIENCE
MEMBER, A MEMBER OF CONGRESS WHO
PASSED AWAY LAST MONTH, SEEMED
TO INDICATE SHE MIGHT BE IN THE
ROOM.
WHAT HAPPENED?
>> SO THE PRESIDENT WAS -- AS
YOU ALL KNOW YOU GUYS WERE
WATCHING TODAY'S EVENT, A VERY
IMPORTANT EVENT ON FOOD
INSECURITY.
THE PRESIDENT WAS NAMING THE
CONGRESSIONAL CHAMPIONS ON THIS
ISSUE.
>> HE SAID JACKIE ARE YOU HERE?
WHERE'S JACKIE SHE MUST NOT BE
HERE.
>> I TOTALLY UNDERSTAND.
I JUST EXPLAINED, SHE WAS ON TOP
OF MIND.
>> I'M TRYING TO GET MY HEAD
AROUND THE RESPONSE.
IF THE LATE CONGRESSWOMAN WAS
TOP OF MIND FOR THE PRESIDENT
AND HER FAMILY WAS EXPECTED TO
HERE AND THAT'S WHAT HE WAS
THINKING ABOUT WHY WAS HE
LOOKING FOR HER?
I'M NOT TRYING TO BE SNARKY
HERE.
>> NO, AND, AGAIN, I THINK
PEOPLE CAN UNDERSTAND.
>> ONE MORE TIME BACK TO THE
QUESTION ABOUT THE
CONGRESSWOMAN.
>> I'M NOT SURE WHY.
WHY?
WHY ONE MORE TIME.
>> THE CONFUSING PART IS WHY, IF
SHE AND THE FAMILY IS TOP OF
MIND, DOES THE PRESIDENT THINK
THAT SHE'S LIVING AND IN THE
ROOM.
>> I DON'T FIND THAT CONFUSING.
>> Sean: JUST SIMPLY TELL THE
TRUTH THAT THE PRESIDENT IS AND
HAS BEEN FOR A LONG TIME A
COGNITIVE WRECK AND OUR COUNTRY
IS FACING CRISES ON MULTIPLE